soll die kids verschwendung mit dem tier
see der neben dem anzapfen nähern
hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video rät schon im titel eingeblendet es
geht wollte mal wieder um eine pizza die
noch gar nicht draußen ist aber
irgendwie ja keine ahnung ich habe mir
einfach unter den letzten video so ein
bisschen nachgeschaut was werden dass
unsere kommentare zu einer pizza
geschrieben und es wird natürlich sehr
positiv ist geschrieben und wieder leute
freuen sich schon darauf ich meine es
ist eine pizza alter wer mag keine pizza
allerdings habe ich auch einige hate
kommentare entdeckt beziehungsweise
fragen auf die ich einfach mal eingehen
wollte deswegen hey du hast keine
produktplatzierung angezeigt lieber
niels ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was
eine produktplatzierung ist aber falls
ein produkt platzierung meinst das war
es auch nicht wenn schon war es ein
werbevideo da das komplette video quasi
nur um die pizza ging da ich allerdings
nie wirklich dafür bezahlt wurde oder
nie wirklich eine kaufaufforderungen
gemacht habe ist es dementsprechend
nicht wörtlich ich habe das mit medien
anwältin abgeklärt ich würde euch damit
natürlich nicht verarschen deswegen wenn
es unbedingt wollte ba jetzt steht hier
irgendwo werbevideo die ganze zeit den
scheiß fresse ich nicht ich könnte jetzt
auch sagen du hast den bvb logo profil
wird auch so einen scheiß antwortet doch
nicht mache ich aber nicht wenn du
meinst dass die pizza scheiße ist
beziehungsweise beschissen und schmeckt
oder so dann brauchst du sie dir nicht
kaufen gehen also ich zwinge keinen dazu
in den supermarkt zu gehen und sich die
pizza zu kaufen aber hey du weißt nicht
mal ob sie schmeckt das ist einfach noch
nicht mal draußen das ist egal wie man
jetzt mal an alle leute die sagen
die wird er total beschissen sein und
total kacke und keine ahnung war ist
also ich weiß nicht was sie nicht
wirklich in diesem video nur auf den
hell des gesetzliche leute die schon
darauf freuen und die sagen ich lasse
mir überraschend ich probiere die
anklamer jedes gerne
ihr dürft gerne über die pizza urteilen
dürfte sich gerne fertig machen ihr
dürft gerne sagen wie scheiße ihr sie
findet wenn ihr sie gegessen habe und
jetzt ist sie einfach noch nicht mal
draußen es macht einfach keinen sinn
dieser ganze hass alter freunde schreibt
mal liebe in die kommentare
das wird viel zu sehr unterbewertet du
kleiner bastard lieber kenne ich music
hey warum heben schade hat rat gefragt
ob ich zu köln darf kann aber nicht
wohnen passau lieber jürgen ich weiß
nicht warum sie das jetzt alles den caps
lock schreibst du mich damit an schreist
aber hey ich wurde können deswegen mache
ich es in köln ich habe so viele
kommentare bekommen von luca wenn du am
17.10
da in dem rewe wissen der bonner straße
in köln und da kostenlos pizza verteilt
15 uhr da kann ich hinkommen habe ich
noch schule ich wohne in berlin ich
wohnen in timbuktu kanaren wo es tut mir
leid aber ich kann es nicht allen recht
machen also wenn ich sage ich mache
jetzt nicht in köln sondern in berlin
weil so viele meinen sie kommen aus
berlin dann sagen alle kölner aus alle
die in bonn und bist du doch und im
umkreis in nrw wohnen sagen ich komme
nicht aus berlin also es tut mir leid
lieber jürgen dass du hast bekommst und
dementsprechend nicht am 17 und 15 uhr
nach köln kommen kann ist wo ich
kostenlos pizza verteiler aber du kannst
du die pizza bestimmt dann irgendwo im
laden kaufen spendet lieber die vier
euro an kinder in afrika anstatt in
diese zu teure pizza das sehe ich
tatsächlich genauso wie du lieber fritz
also natürlich wie bei 4 euro irgendwie
spenden an arme kinder an keine ahnung
wie man hilfsorganisationen anstatt in
eine pizza zu investieren aber die pizza
kostet auch weniger als vier euro aber
das ist ein anderes thema aber ich kann
jetzt genauso sagen
bevor du hier den kommentar schreiben
und einem internetfähigen endgerät muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen willst du doch
auch die 500 euro die den handykosten
1000 euro die dann die c klasse kostet
kannst du doch auch einfach mal spenden
oder da kann man genauso kommentieren
die pizza kostet fünf euro
sma hat ihr mir nicht richtig zu in dem
blog wo ich euch zeigen wie meine pizza
hergestellt habe ich euch gesagt die
pizza wird vier euro kosten das war
zuviel die pizza wir zwischen drei euro
49 und 379 liegen das liegt ganz einfach
daran dass jeder einzelne lewe quasi
selbst sagen kann ok ich biete die für
drei euro 49 an das ist so wie die bei
uns quasi aus der produktion rausgeht
oder die sagen hey komm ist der bau wird
keine ahnung also die wir zwischen 43
und 39 70 liegen also ich weiß nicht
woher sich so viele leute diese fünf
euro nehme auch bei twitter voll viele
möchtegern keine ahnung journalisten
gaming redakteure kommen fünf euro für
pizza gehört immer zu alter die kostet
safe zwischen drei euro 49 und drei euro
79 und wenn doch irgendeiner ankommt und
sagt sie kostet fünf euro oder keine
ahnung was also zu dem fall ich
persönlich nach hause um 13 8 das wäre
so endhardt special pizza mit vielleicht
sagen die stücke mit mini form statt
dessen ist dass lh ganz normale
margaritas jury hätte aber mehr erwartet
liebe auf fische an
wieso bist du auf fische das ist ein
kommentar den ich auch sehr häufig
bekommen habe und zwar meinten dann
leute ich hätte echt gedacht dass die
pizza vielleicht aus käse erstmalig vom
drauf hat oder so sagen stückchen wo
sonst mal drauf gewinnst ist das habe
ich auch schon sehr häufig gesagt und
auch schon sehr häufig beantwortet
diesen kommentar wenn man so etwas
man möchte muss man den kompletten
produktionsprozess forum stellen ja
vielleicht den block gesehen wo ich die
gezeigt hat wie die pizza hergestellt
wird das ganze besteht aus sieben
stationen dass der teig ist fertig von
hand gemacht dann kommt zu machen so per
anruf dann wird es in den steinofen
gebacken ich glaube ihr habt alle das
video gesehen also das muss jetzt noch
mal alles erklären wenn ich allerdings
möchte dass der käse darin dass miley
formen drauf kommt oder dass da eine
salami stückchen mit einem eingravierten
smiley noch draufgelegt wird oder so
dann müssen wir quasi eine neue maschine
kaufen solche maschinen kostet auch wenn
sie gebraucht sind teilweise fast
siebenstellig und so viel geld habe ich
nicht was unsere idee erst mal so ein
bisschen ist ist wir bringen eine pizza
margherita raus unser us- so ein
bisschen das spiel sehr viel größer sind
als die konkurrenz ich zeige
beispielsweise hier ein foto
[Musik]
also da habt ihr jetzt gerade den
unterschied gesehen zwischen einer ganz
normalen tiefkühlpizza und quasi unserer
tiefkühlpizza also ihr seht schon die
ist viel größer und das ist so der
hauptmerkmal unsere pizza zudem gar
nicht jetzt auch sagen es werden nur
regional aus zutaten ausgewählt von hand
hergestellt wird in einem steinhofen
vorgebacken sie wird schockgefrostet die
verpackung
ich wache muss ich mich so für
rechtfertigen ich glaube das muss ich
gar nicht aber ich mache es irgendwie
weil ich mich sehr viel auf diesen hält
immer konzentriere und es irgendwie
jedem recht machen will aber ich bin
ganz ehrlich wenn diese pizza gut läuft
wenn ich sehe ok euch gefällt die pizza
dann nehme ich sehr sehr viel geld in
die hand dass die nächste pizza übels
geil wird also bitte probiert die pizza
einfach oder wenn ihr keine lust hat
dafür geld auszugeben oder wenn euch
diese drei euro 49 zu teuer sind kommt
gerne
17 10 wenn die bonner straße 211 in köln
dort verteile ich kostenlos tipps da ist
jeder ne pizza hut und ja dann könnt ihr
die gerne probieren und danach könnten
hätten warum nicht den 18 10 2010 dann
hätte ich an dem tag geburtstag wie
barbian ich selbst habe am 18 19
namenstag welcher mensch feiert
eigentlich noch namenstag also das datum
wäre schon cool gewesen aber wir dachten
17 2017 das ist halt so 17 10 17
das ist eigentlich ein ganz cooles datum
deswegen haben wir den tag ausgewählt
weil die kids verschwendung mit dem tier
see der neben text sagt wiek annähern
diesen kommentar musste ich so häufig
lesen dabei ging es um eine szene bei
der ich im blog gezeigt habe wie der
käse auf die pizza fällt hier mal ein
ganz kurzer ausschnitt ihr seht ihr
schon freunde hier wird immer nahezu
fast genau gleiche these auf die
einzelne pizzen raumwunder meinten so
unglaublich viele leute etwa die hälfte
des käses fällt neben die pizza
adaptieren die hier eine neue ankommt
altar das hier ist das fließband auf dem
fließband kommen die verschiedenen
pizzen aus dem steinofen dann fällt der
käse drauf und der käse fällt natürlich
gleichmäßig rauf und der krise der
daneben ist der fällt dann am ende des
bandes runter auf ein weiteres fließband
dieses vlies bahn fährt nach oben wieder
hin und der käse wird wieder oben
gleichmäßig drauf gelagert da wird
nichts verschwendet das werde auch total
gut für uns weil wir dann doppelt den
käse einfach als er ab sorry aber ich
verstehe so was nicht vor allem hat man
sie im blog auf gesehen an der kurzen
stelle wie das einer seite wieder
hochgefahren ist der käse schmeckt halt
einfach deine fresse louis ganzem herz
für solche kommentare habe ich wirklich
nichts übrig als die pizza ist nicht mal
draußen
schon draußen wäre würde ich so ein
kommentar komplett respektieren aber die
kommt jetzt in der woche ich schwöre ich
komme mir auch einen zeugen können wir
eine kostenlose pizza von dirk an api
für ihren mann elwy kommt habe ich so
gefeiert 50 cent weniger bei lidl
bekomme ich drei pizzen sind 250 aber
die pizza ist eben auch eine art merge
und wird dadurch teurer ehrlich gesagt
dass diese pizza für mich keine art
merge ich habe letztens von youtube
angehört die verdienen an pullis 25 euro
an einem pulli ich verdiene an der pizza
5 cent und ich weiß nicht ob man
wirklich in anderen supermärkten drei
pizzen für zwei euro fünfzig bekommen
dann wird jede pizza irgendwie so 70
cent kosten oder so deswegen hab ich
möchte dir solchen pizzen ehrlich er
ungern essen/bonn halt morgen nach
macher der arme macht die logins nett da
und ich bete nächste woche ab meine
eigene schumacher gott hdm keine ahnung
was hdm heißt aber okay ich weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht wo ich die lobbys nach
mache also ich habe ehrlich gesagt nach
dem lesen des kommentars direkt mal die
logins pizza gegoogelt habe nichts
gefunden
sorry und ganz im ernst wenn upgrade
nächste woche eine schumacher raus
bringt dann kann ich das cool weil ab
uhr entsteht so ein bisschen für schuhe
jedes mal in seinen videos die bei dem
mittag und diese unzähligen sneaker und
weiter und so fort also das finde ich
würde perfekt zu ihm passen ich für
meinen teil es unglaublich gerne pizza
und liebe pizza und zeige dass auch und
rede darüber auch recht offen deswegen
hey was ist deine veranstaltern viel
kritik für adcom kraft das pizza dabei
ist ein sportwagen fahren der
pizzabäcker mit fragwürdigem
nebeneinkommen doch was ganz normales
diesen tweet wollen weil wohnzimmer aus
gesendet oder funk ich weiß nicht wer da
den twitter account von denen macht und
ich mein mit dem ersten satz haben sie
recht viel kritik bekommen
das spitze kam echt einiges zusammen
aber sportwagen-fans ich fahren min also
wenn man mit sportwagen ist und wer ist
ultra coole zudem bin ich kein
pizzabäcker weil ich glaube man hat den
blog gesehen dass ich das tatsächlich
nicht so gut kommt und dass sie bei
meinen kollegen dabei gustavo gusto
überlassen und dann steht ihr noch
fragwürdiges nebeneinkommen das was ist
denn bitte fragwürdiges nebeneinkommen
jetzt auf mich bezogen also wie bei
dennis lieber wenn ich weiß edith
rausgehauen hat oder eben wer bei euch
davon funk oder so aber was wollt ihr
damit erreichen also ich dachte mir
freunde harry soll das pflaster ist wie
ausrufezeichen eck das ist jetzt nicht
auf die pizza bezogen aber mutiert
mutter mal raus ausprobiert weil ich
meine das ist vielleicht gefährlich
hautkrebs die stores aber nicht komplett
ungefährlich ist sieht gerade so aus
also das pflaster ist weg und hier ist
jetzt auch so eine kleine narbe also
herr idei gibt es die pizza in
österreich das tut mir unglaublich leid
das sagen zu müssen aber die pizza wird
es vorerst nicht in österreich und auch
nicht in der schweiz geben weil gustavo
musst du einfach leider nur in
deutschland gelistet es aber wir führen
derzeit schon gespräch mit anderen
supermarktketten und unter anderem auch
in anderen ländern also eventuell tut
sich dann einiger zeit was deine pizza
pumpt schmeckt echt gut das ist zwar
jetzt ein positiver kommentar und kein
held aber ich wollte trotzdem mit rein
nehmen
und das gleiche darauf antworten die auf
die kommentare von vorhin die pizza ist
noch nicht draußen
ihr könnt nicht wissen wie sich schmeckt
also bitte wartet ab und urteilt dann
kannst du mal locken bitte da muss ich
immer so lachen cooles video macht
weiter so ist jetzt auch kein hague
wollte ich trotzdem mit rein nehmen weil
ich den kommentar auch in letzter zeit
sehr häufig so komme da viele leute
wieder die blogs vermissen aber wäre
nicht die ganze zeit geblockt haben
viele leute gaming videos und solche
videos wie ich jetzt gerade machen
vermisst also ich kann man kann es als
üblich war glaube ich nie allen recht
machen ich habe mir vorgenommen dass ich
in nächster zeit nur darum bloggen werde
wenn wirklich was interessantes passiert
also wenn ich weiß ich liege irgendwo
hin zum beispiel bin ich nicht nächstes
wochenende sondern danach das wochenende
drei tage in amsterdam da werde ich
locken allgemein werden wir morgen
erstmal die weisheitszähne raus genommen
also da werden erstmals vier tage lang
entweder keine videos kommen oder videos
wo ich fett gebacken habe aber genau
main kanal sollte jetzt wieder so ein
bisschen in die ältere richtung gehen
also ich wollte jetzt bald wieder
microsoft bringt anfangen mit max zettl
unter anderem deswegen kommen dann quasi
blogs nur wirklich wenn ihnen was
spannendes passiert also hey lass doch
mal ein like dafür ist jetzt ihr vom
video meine damen und herren es euch
gefallen hat das gerne man leider habe
ich glaube ich vor zehn sekunden schon
gesagt noch mal auf die pizza
zurückzukommen wartet wirklich wie
gesagt einmal den siebzehnten habe geht
vielleicht dann riesig 93 teuer sind
kommt gerne um 17 10 nach köln zum rewe
da werde ich nämlich kostenlos pizza
verteilt aber bitte jetzt nicht vorher
die ganze zeit sagen ey die ist scheiße
und blabla probiert sie einfach also
meiner meinung nach ist es die beste
tief gewisse die ich je gegessen habe
das was jetzt hier versetzt
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]